[Music]
welcome to your new home
you want to hear a story i love stories
the movie but one and only ivan is based
on a book
that is based on real-life events for
one
and only ivan
there really was a very special gorilla
called ivan and he really knew how to
draw whoa did you draw all these
a gorilla who draws ivan is played by
the brilliant sam rockwell can you tell
what this is uh
a cheeto it's a key danny devito is
playing bob
now we're talking there's so many people
enjoy the show
let me add him you've got to love him
and also shaka khan
so the greatest casting ever
[Music]
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback a terrified humans
you're not terrifying it's a beautiful
story they're really a family trying to
work together
to get a second chance the wild yeah
that's where we belong what i loved
about the story was that
you get to experience an incredible
journey with these animals
the story is really about learning that
it's
never too late to find out who you
really are we're in this together
we're family it's really nice to be a
part of something that you feel
has something really good to say
[Applause]
rated pg streaming august 21st on disney
plus